ich glaube schon dass wir in einer
varitablen Staatskrise sind in einer
dauerhaften Wirtschaftskrise ohnehin es
fällt ja auf dass um uns herum die
Wirtschaft trotz der internationalen
Rahmenbedingungen eher wächst
Deutschland geht zurück und sofern haben
wir jetzt zwei echte Probleme das eine
ist dass eine Regierung de facto
handlungsunfähig ist meiner nach
selbstverschuldet durch eben das Urteil
des Bundesverfassungsgericht und zum
anderen dass wir keine echte
Wirtschaftsstrategie haben gibt auch
Leute die sagen Neuwahlen in der
jetzigen Situation wäre eine denkbare
Variante ist auch schwierig auch
schwierig wenn keine Regierung zustande
Brechten wenn jetzt die FDP ausscheidet
es gibt keine Regierung die zustande
kommt ich habe vor Wochen schon gesagt m
ich gescholten
war gesagt also mit FDP und grün wird's
nicht gehen die Fliehkräfte sind so groß
ich halte sie nicht für regierungsfähig
Scholz soll quasi die Partner die er
jetzt hat entlassen wir stünden bereit
um in der Notsituation vielleicht
Verantwortung zu übernehmen wurde alles
abgelehnt und die Union wä es
dann